screaming show with how Rudnick happy
2013 everybody we're all still here john
cusack and roland emmerich must be
pissed it's a new year guys
time to rag on new things or old things
that Hollywood is trying to reboot and
turn into new things that leads me to
our new segment talking Joe
so talking junk is a new segment where
we offer a forum to people to complain
[ __ ] and moan about an issue that is
burning inside of them with us today is
NIC Mundy Nick what do you want to
complain about today die hard 5 oh you
mean a good day to die hard I'm not
calling about it's not 5
he's already fired up to get them even
more fired up let's watch the trailer
for die hard 5 damn it dad
try not to make an even bigger messes
ins I will say that the opening looks a
little bit like Meet the Fockers it's
like dad don't do anything goofy oh now
I'm an old guy sitting between two
models
this isn't your Grandpa's die hard well
it is your grandmother's die are because
Bruce Willis looks like he's 70 years
old yeah so I really liked the t-mobile
girls in this one always wanted to see
her naked
Jack dad that's his son they couldn't
get Joseph Warren loved it well word on
the street as they lost the nose
prosthetic that they used in looper need
a hood and had a hood and family damn
string Bruce Willis looks bored out of
his mind
I blame the studio I blame the director
for not getting Bruce Willis engaged
Nick you have a lot of complaints it's
easy to have any solutions yeah I do
the first thing that fox need to do is
stick to the basics and the first die
hard John McClane was in LA he was a New
York cop and it was one guy against 12
terrorists mom machine oh oh oh it was
believable it was awesome
but in the fourth diehard he's literally
fighting the internet covering the
camera with your hand it's not turn off
the microphone and if that can be worse
he is fighting a jet how does that work
next just because Len Wiseman directed
the fourth eye hard doesn't mean every
other sequel has to look like underworld
stop with the CGI stop with the slow-mo
this looks like The Watchmen and there
needs to be blood squids not the digital
kind I'm talking about the Robocop blood
squibs where you see them form and
coagulate in the middle of the air
that's what needs to happen in die hard
thanks for the advice remember the first
die hard when Sean McClane one guy
against a whole group of terrorists
that's what diehards about it's not a
buddy cop movie you don't need sidekicks
how you doing hi skin my name my
asthma's I think I'm good what about Sam
Jackson in the third one you're a racist
you don't like me cuz I'm white I don't
like you because you're gonna get me
killed 1995 was the year of Sam Jackson
of course you're gonna put Sam Jackson
in it you're not gonna put Justin long
or this other guy
oh you mean Jai Courtney of Spartacus
vengeance Fame on Starz
everything you said hurts my feelings do
you really think you have a chance
against us mr. cowboy
I don't know who you have planned for
the bad guy but make them approver that
certain British gay thing that like all
good Gruber men have German British
Russian gay things yeah one of them if I
could sum that up Nick you're saying all
Europeans are gay oh if we could please
make it a rated hour die hard
the pg-13 diehard sucked John McClane
needs to say every other line his
channel is reserved for emergency calls
only oh lady noise sound like I'm worn a
pizza I kind of don't mind the broadcast
television version where he says yippie
Kay yay mr. Falcon you think is mr.
Falcon
that's kinda neat mr. Falcon ah ah
next Bruce Willis Kruger big hair out I
don't care if you have a fryer I don't
care if it's great
you are the hero for every balding man
in the world stop looking like Scott Van
Pelt right oh my god
it's a lot of rage Nick it could be
worse they could get rid of Bruce Willis
and put Taylor Kitsch in there no no no
no no no okay mother Nick made some
valid points there so it's a die hard
six we called surf Nazis must die hard
walk die hard with a vengeance get rich
or die hard trying
hey it's 2013 it's The Annoying time for
new year's resolutions again what do you
want to see less up from Hollywood do
not say the screen junkies show with Hal
Rudnick because my ex-girlfriend Eileen
already said that and things did not end
well with her
Helene if you're watching you can return
a text every once in a while tell us
your Hollywood New Year's resolutions in
the comments below best answer get the
screen junkies t-shirt I'm Hal Rudnick
bye bye it's time for the screen
jeez this home alone sequel goes to
Skyfall come on did you see the way they
rigged that house at the end I was
waiting for Joe Pesci and Daniel Stern
to bust in there